oulan bator sept cent mille habitants
capitale de la mongolie un ancien état
de l'union soviétique
sûrement le plus pauvre depuis dix ans
presque toutes les mines de charbon et
de cuivre ont fermé jetant à la rue des
familles entières
mais ici la température est mortelle
sept mois sur 12
elle descend à moins 30 degrés parfois
moins 40 encore plus vulnérables que les
adultes les enfants livrés à eux-mêmes
et prêt à se réfugier n'importe où pour
survivre
[Musique]
m
jukka à 13 ans et déjà quatre années de
rue derrière lui abandonné par ses
parents
recueilli par une famille d'accueil qui
ne nourrit pas il a choisi la rue
aujourd'hui quelques tomates serviront
de repas tout cas ne sait jamais de quoi
sa journée sera faite ni quand il pourra
manger de nouveau
nyama huit ans est orphelin lui aussi
tout cas l'a pris sous son aile comme un
grand frère
car ici les bandes d'enfants ne se font
pas de cadeaux mais pourquoi t'as pas de
choisir
on s'est bagarré hier avec déplorant que
non il n'y en avait un qui n'avait pas
de chaussures me voler les miennes
[Musique]
et il m'a pris mon blouson aussi pour
survivre il faut d'abord trouver des
sous les touristes croisé dans le centre
ville sont les proies les plus faciles
pour récolter quelques pièces
[Musique]
je reviens dans quelques minutes
mais cette dame ne reviendra pas et le
froid commence à faire mal
nyama le plus jeune de la bande a besoin
de se réchauffer dans ces cas là ils
savent où trouver un abri sous la terre
à oulan bator on appelle ça une tranchée
un trou de quatre mètres sur trois
jonché de détritus mais au moins ici il
fait chaud les canalisations de la ville
servent de chauffage central vous venez
souvent ici ouais ouais on vient pour
dans quelques fois on va ailleurs dans
des tranchées local ou dans des halls
d'immeuble le problème dans les
tranchées c'est qu'il ya souvent des
adultes ils sont ivres ils nous frappent
et une chasse
mais il faut faire attention les tuyaux
peuvent chauffer jusqu'à 100 degrés et
tuer ceux qui s'endorment dessus moi je
me suis allé souvent regardé ici et ici
aussi
un jour j'ai pas fait attention j'ai mis
ma main sur un tuyau brûlant et je me
suis gravement blessé
[Musique]
à oulan bator plus de 400 enfants vivent
sous la terre comme des rats
[Musique]
dell guerre à cinq ans c'est peut-être
la plus jeune des enfants des rues
d'oulan bator
pour survivre elle fait les poubelles
avec son grand frère manqué neuf ans il
cherche des canettes qu'ils revendront
pour quelques pièces
tu peux essayer de me soulever non je
peux pas
la cie toi soul est noir d'accord
arrête arrête j'ai pas envie combien tu
vas vendre chaque canette d'un centime
par canette et par jour tu arrives à en
ramasser combien on peut ramasser
jusqu'à 50
banque edel guerre eux ne sont pas
orphelins ils ont des parents mais ils
préfèrent la rue plutôt que les coûts
leur père est alcoolique et violent
hier soir mon père m'a battue pourquoi
il t'a battu sans raison j'étais à la
maison et tout à coup il s'est mis à me
frapper
il était ivre et a frappé fort oui tu as
pleuré
oui et à seurre il l'a frappé aussi non
c'est juste ton frère qui s'est fait
battre le père de delgrès manqué n'est
pas le seul alcoolique en mongolie
l'alcool est un fléau national qui
touche d'abord les familles les plus
démunies pour dell guère évoqué
l'errance continue toujours à la
recherche de quelques canettes mais le
pire est à venir
la nuit tombe très tôt et avec elle le
froid glacial
il est 19 heures la température et de
loi 25 degrés
tout cas et ses copains ont décidé de
braver le froid pour laver des voitures
devant un restaurant huppé du centre
ville voilà je la mets voiture l'effort
et la journée parfois je travaille au
marché qu'est ce que tu fais mon marché
mes jeux par des sacs de farine et pour
se faire payer tout cas à une technique
bien rodée tu as demandé si tu pouvais
laver la voiture et comment tu vas
récupérer l'argent va aller voir le
chauffeur quand il sortira du resto et
dire que sa voiture est la seule que
j'ai lavé et qu'il me doit de l'argent
s'ils ne veut pas payer jusqu'à son être
un touriste japonais éméché et amusé par
le spectacle va se montrer généreux avec
les enfants quelques euros une somme
dérisoire mais pour ces enfants une
petite fortune qu'ils vont se partager
sous le contrôle de tout cas assez
d'argent en tout cas pour quitter les
lieux
s'acheter quelques biscuits en guise de
dîner et se réfugier ensuite bien au
chaud dans un hall d'immeuble dont ils
connaissent le code d'accès
ça fait combien de temps que tu es parti
de chez toi là ça fait dix jours à peu
près comme twitter j'y retourne
plusieurs par plusieurs tours tu préfère
être dans la rue ou chez toi dans la rue
c'est mieux je me sens bien on fait ce
qu'on veut dehors et avec mes copains on
s'amuse bien ça arrive souvent de rester
sans manche juste ça arrive tu peux
passer combien de jours sans manger
samareh de rester cinq jours sans manger
l'arrivée de cette femme qui habite
l'immeuble va perturber leur dîner elle
ne montre aucun signe d'agressivité
aucun étonnement non plus mais très
souvent les habitants des loges les
enfants et font appel à la police
tu peux être sûr qu'elle était en train
d'appeler les flics
tout cas et ses copains préfère
déguerpir avant l'arrivée de la police
ils vont devoir passer la nuit dans
leurs tranchées
oui allez en route il fait trop froid
ok on y voit attention aux descendants
faites gaffe ou mettez les mains c'est
avec afar partout regard celui là il est
énorme
regarde regarde mais non dans tambouille
tabou centre et quelques-uns à deux
cuillères à thé ya d'autres bestioles
ici il ya tout ça les cafards des rats
des souris des araignées de gens mon
dieu il te grève comme ça et des chiens
qui viennent te mordre comme ça il
ratera pas trop vos boutiques et qu'il
était et puis tu sais tu as des cafards
qui peuvent te rentrer dans la bouche
quand tu dors tu étais tout feuilleter
un bémol il ya des gens qui meurent ici
il y en a même qui se font tuer vous
tous
[Musique]
cette nuit ils vont dormir au chaud mais
demain ils devront encore se battre pour
ne pas mourir de faim ni de froid
quelques mètres au dessus le capitaine
dav a fait sa ronde
il est 23h avec son collègue 100 da ils
appartiennent à la brigade des mineurs
leur mission pour accueillir les enfants
des rues depuis cinq ans le capitaine
d'havas on a sauvé des milliers
[Applaudissements]
allez vous venez avec moi mais moi je
suis avec mon grand frère
non non tu viens avec nous aussi
attention en voiture allait monter
les enfants se laissera t elle sans trop
résister oui en général ça va il y en a
quelques-uns qui font des difficultés
mais c'est une minorité
les trottoirs les halls d'immeuble les
magasins le capitaine connaît tous les
recoins où se cachent des enfants
à commencer par les tranchées l'asmo la
lente
tu sais c'est un adulte alors on la
laisse le la pour les adultes on peut
rien faire pour nous notre mission c'est
de ramasser les enfants de moins de 16
ans
[Musique]
ce soir là le capitaine a vite fait de
remplir sa vieille camionnette russe
mais sa tournée n'est pas fini d'autres
tranches et l'attendent
[Musique]
john
dans celle ci il n'y a pas que des
adultes le capitaine fait sortir un
enfant d'une dizaine d'années
[Musique]
vous savez chaque bouche d'égout à son
nom comme une adresse ici par exemple
cette tranche et s'appelle la tranchée
17 wagons
lorsqu'on est près de la gare il ya sept
blocs hlm
en fait ils changent très souvent de
trancher à peine occupé elles sont aussi
vite abandonnée si je revenais à celle
là demain par exemple
c'est fort possible qu'on y trouve
personne
[Musique]
la tournée s'achève cette fois la
camionnette est pleine elle allait
rentrer au foyer de la police quand
soudain regarde y en a deux la hausse à
à thoirette toi manqué et sa petite
soeur d'albert il est 3 heures du matin
et le froid est insupportable vous allez
dormir ou ce soir allez venez avec moi
on part ensemble d'accords allez on y va
les enfants ne perd pas on lui fait peur
je crois arrête de pleurer ta soeur elle
pleure pas elle
où
[Musique]
et
bilan de la nuit une vingtaine d'enfants
ramassées depuis son ouverture il ya
sept ans plus de dix mille enfants sont
passés par le foyer de la police un
foyer accueillant mais trop petit
seulement 50 lits dès leur arrivée les
enfants sont recensés l'objectif
connaître leurs noms et leurs adresses
pour prévenir la famille des
informations souvent difficile à obtenir
avec les tout-petits comme dell guerre
et son frère c'est quoi ton adresse
savez où vous habitez les enfants elle
est où ta maison
vous savez pas
elle tombe en mêlée où cette banlieue
savent pas où ils habitent vous
connaissez pas votre adresse
d'accord ici les enfants seront vus par
un médecin et même par un psychologue
s'ils le souhaitent
mais d'abord ils doivent quitter leurs
vêtements crasseux ils seront passés à
la lessive
ensuite direction la douche dell guerre
et les autres enfants ne se sont pas
lavés depuis plusieurs jours on va aussi
leur mettre des vêtements propres
là ils ont pris leur douche et
maintenant ils vont aller dormir un peu
demain matin on va essayer d'obtenir une
adresse précise pour localiser les
parents et les prévenir après asus est
le règlement du foyer stricte les
garçons d'un côté les filles de l'autre
mais ce soir le capitaine va faire une
exception dell guerre pourra dormir avec
son grand frère
[Musique]
au foyer les enfants sont en sursis si
leurs familles ne donne aucun signe de
vie avant sept jours ils seront placés
dans un orphelinat une semaine à passer
manque est toujours là et sa soeur
d'elle guerre jamais très loin
personne ne s'est préoccupé de leur sort
vous avez des nouvelles de vos parents
ils sont pas venu vous chercher
personne n'a demandé de vos nouvelles
personnes choquées
pourtant la dernière fois ma mère était
venue me chercher
[Musique]
bonjour à tous ça va bien vous êtes
prêts pour le déjeuner a bon appétit
tout le monde
en général quand les parents recherchent
leurs enfants et les localisent ici ils
viennent les chercher mais ça nous
arrive aussi de les ramener chez eux si
personne ne se manifeste
notre mission à nous n'est pas du tout
répressive
on essaie de remettre les enfants dans
le droit chemin de les éduquer un peu de
les réconforter ils leur apporter un peu
d'affection
aujourd'hui le capitaine d'havas devrait
placer manqué et sa soeur dans un
orphelinat mais il veut tout faire pour
leur éviter ça alors dis moi comment
vous faites pour manger dehors il ya des
journées hommages il y a dix jours ne
mangent pas entre temps j'ai envie de
rentrer chez toi maintenant j'aimerais
bien
alors ça y est on rentre chez nous se
contente de rentrer chez toi tu viens
l'a battu assez à manger c'est pas trop
dur à la maison avec ton père sava les
bois de l'alcool
oui ils boivent beaucoup d'alcool
non il boit pas si c'est vrai vous voyez
les parents ont une grande
responsabilité dans tout ça quand les
parents procure de l'infection aux
enfants ils ne partent pas dans leur cas
à eux ils m'ont expliqué que leurs
parents ne travaillent pas et ne peuvent
pas les nourrir les enfants ont pris
conscience de la situation et ont décidé
de même de partir il l'a dit lui même le
petit comme chez moi y'a rien à manger
ça me donne envie de partir team battle
il est donc parti chercher de la
nourriture en emmenant sa petite soeur
avec lui
le capitaine ne connaît pas l'adresse
des deux enfants mais seulement le
quartier où il habite
il espère que sur place ils
reconnaîtront leurs maisons comment
réagissent les parents quand vous
ramener les enfants
il y en a qui sont contents d'autres
nous demandent pourquoi on les a ramenés
la vérité c'est que dans la majorité des
cas les parents ne sont pas vraiment
content de les revoir
après avoir tourné plus d'une heure
monde qui reconnaît en face à maison là
bas juste au coin pied dehors bien là
que tu habites allez vas-y
leurs parents habitent une yourte la
maison traditionnelle mongole sans eau
ni électricité dans une des banlieues
les plus pauvres d'où la nouba tort
bonjour voila je vous ramène vos enfants
on les a eu quelques jours au foyer
on les a ramassées dans le centre
l'autre soir on va remplir les papiers
prouvant je vous les est bien ramené
jusqu'ici quand sa mère approche la
petite dalle guerre se réfugie
discrètement derrière le capitaine
aucune émotion aucune réaction de la
part des parents pourtant ils n'ont pas
vu leurs enfants depuis plus d'une
semaine
tu es contente d'être ici
normal que vos enfants traînent dehors
la nuit
bien sûr que non ce n'est pas normal
j'étais très inquiète d'ailleurs j'ai ma
mère est malade et j'étais à l'hôpital à
lesquelles ces derniers jours et quand
je suis rentrée les enfants n'étaient
plus là le capitaine d'havas n'est pas
dupe mais il ne peut rien faire si ce
n'est quelques remontrances à la maman
il va falloir un peu mieux surveiller
vos enfants madame il faut pas que ça
recommence essayer de construire un
foyer chaleureux où ils se sentent bien
il est pas envie de partir tout le temps
s'ils fuga nouveaux venaient me voir au
foyer tout de suite votre mari le bois
non ils frappent vos enfants pour non
mais alors pourquoi vos enfants
s'enfuient qui suivent d'autres enfants
je n'y peux rien c'est comme ça c'est
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup d'enfants qui
traînent dehors qu'est ce qui les attire
de je ne sais pas ils sont à la maison
et soudain disparaissent c'est même pas
la peine de leur courir après allez
c'est fini d'aller faire les yeux dehors
accord maintenant vous dites au revoir
et merci au revoir
allez au revoir les enfants
à votre avis ils vont retourner dans la
rue oui il ya de fortes chances pour que
ça recommence
pourquoi lorsque le contexte familial
est propice à ça vous avez bien vu il
n'y avait rien à manger pour aujourd'hui
dans l' ue il préfère la rue
malheureusement oui vous savez c'est dur
pour un enfant d'avoir faim alors ils
préfèrent aller traîner en ville
mendier et chercher de la nourriture
regardez ils sont déjà sortis
la nuit est tombée sur oulan bator il
fait à nouveau moi 25
le capitaine d'havas avait raison
manquer sa petite soeur ont encore
quitté leur maison sans un sou sans
savoir où dormir
[Musique]
cette nuit encore ils vont devoir
survivre
[Musique]